[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
ein kunde also von mir und das sind die
themen von heute
amerika unter schock mindestens 19
kinder sterben bei einem amoklauf an
einer grundschule in texas
entlastung für millionen mieter an der
klimaabgabe für wohngebäude sollen sich
künftig auch vermieter beteiligen
und zurück in der zweiten liga der erste
fc kaiserslautern gewinnt die relegation
gegen dynamo dresden und steigt aus
wieder ein amoklauf an einer us
amerikanischen schule wieder ist der
täter ein jugendlicher fassungslos
blickt die welt auf mindestens 21
todesopfer 19 kinder und zwei lehrkräfte
der täter wurde von der polizei
erschossen
trauer schmerz und wut in new audi einer
kleinstadt im südwesten von texas der 18
jährige drang in die schule ein und
schoss um sich alle opfer kommen aus
einer klasse als nation müssen wir uns
fragen so der us-präsident wann in
gottes namen bieten wir der waffenlobby
die stirn aus den usa matti wissen
sie haben das wertvollste verloren was
es gibt ihre kinder unter hingabe lopez
10 jahre voller lebensfreude sagt seine
familie es ist gerade mittag als der
schütze leben und hoffnungen zerstört
mit halbautomatischen waffen dringt er
in die grundschule ein ermordet 19
mädchen und jungen und zwei erwachsene
trifft die menschen im kleinen auch den
ihre herzen juve hat 15.000 einwohner
polizisten konnten den 18-jährigen
salvador nach einem feuergefecht
erschießen er stammt aus einer
zerrütteten familie wurde häufig gemobbt
gerade erst konnte er an seinem
geburtstag problemlos die waffenkauf
us-präsident beiden sichtlich
erschütterte entschlossen einmal mehr
eine verschärfung der waffengesetze
anzugehen
weil um gottes willen stehen wir endlich
auf gegen die waffenlobby
die flaggen auf halbmast aber
republikaner im kongress verweigern ihre
unterstützung schon seht ihr demokraten
und viele in den medien die das
verfassungsmäßige recht gesetzestreuer
bürger einschränken
ich flehe sie an meine kollegen warum
machen sie sich die mühe in den us senat
zu kommen wenn ihre einzige antwort auf
das massensterben auf kinder die um ihr
leben rennen wenn ihre einzige antwort
ist dass wir nichts tun
kaviar america osa annabelle und viele
mehr amerika ist das einzige land der
erde dass es mörder und so einfach macht
leben und hoffnungen zu zerstören
fangen wir m at wissen in washington
wird diese große opferzahl dazu
beitragen dass sich jetzt was ändert
ich glaube nicht dass erinnerte an den
fall von sandy hoch grundschule in
connecticut vor knapp zehn jahren damals
in 26 menschen getötet worden damals gab
es auch sehr viele versprechungen aber
seit dem ist eigentlich nichts passiert
außer dass es
3500 weitere massaker in den usa gegeben
hat also schießereien bei denen mehr als
vier personen getötet worden sind es gab
keine verschärfung der waffengesetze und
das liegt an den fehlenden politischen
mehrheiten man bräuchte hier im senat in
washington mindestens zehn
republikanische senatoren die mit für
eine verschärfung stimmen das ist nicht
in sicht also setzten die demokraten
darauf die mehrheiten zu verändern bei
wahlen jetzt im november sind
kongresswahlen aber es ist
unwahrscheinlich dass die mehrheiten
groß genug werden weil eben für viele
amerikaner dieses thema nicht das
wichtigste thema ist dankeschön für
diese einschätzung live aus washington
mrt wissen wir dass das ringen um die
waffengesetze dazu spricht zdf heute
live um 19.30 ausführlich mit elmar
theveßen auf den social media kanälen
und in der zdf- heute- app dort haben
wir auch zusammengefasst was präsident
biden tun will und kann um die waffen
gewalt einzudämmen
zum krieg in der ukraine
dort gerät die ukrainische front ins
wanken mit massiven angriffen haben
russische truppen in den vergangenen
tagen ukrainische truppen aus mehreren
ortschaften im osten des landes
vertrieben präsident seelands gesagt das
werde große anstrengungen brauchen um
die russische überlegenheit an rüstung
und technik zu überwinden volker check
berichtet
eine stadt gezeichnet von drei monaten
krieg sie wäre donetsk in der ost
ukraine unter dauerbeschuss seitdem
moskau seine truppen zusammengezogen hat
und weniger ziele umso intensiver
angreift allein heute sechs tote und
acht verletzt wegen seiner
verkehrsanbindung und seiner lage ist so
wäre dann jetzt strategisch wichtig das
ziel mit der eroberten stadt im rücken
könnte moskau weitere regionen in der
ukraine angreifen gleiches gilt für die
schwesterstadt dc tschanz jetzt
versuchen die russen beide städte von
drei seiten einzupreisen die russische
armee hat offenbar ihre strategie
geändert das glauben zumindest us
militärexperten moskau verzichtet jetzt
auf die große einkreisung ukrainischer
streitkräfte stattdessen sollen die
us-truppen an vielen kleinen
einkesselung zermürbt und zerschlagen
werden ukrainische präsident selensky
ist überzeugt dass sie wäre dann jäh
zerstört werden soll und nennt mit
leichten atemzug andere ziele die in das
gleiche schicksal drohe etwa wie man
pasta slawinski unter beschuss liegen
rund 40 städte und ortschaften im don
was das staatsfernsehen zeigt putin bald
verletzten im krankenhaus äußerlich
unversehrte soldaten im smalltalk mit
ihrem präsidenten die botschaft zum bild
könnte sein kommt zur armee hier kümmern
wir uns auch um die verletzten
johannes hano in und des fahrers können
sie uns über die militärische lage sagen
also die angriffe im donbass sind
besonders schwer es hat ihr heute
massive raketenangriffe im ganzen land
gegeben da sind mehrere fabriken
zerstört worden und wir sind heute
morgen schon um halb fünf von schwerem
luft damen hier nur besser aus den
betten gescheucht worden die ukrainische
armee hat gesagt die russischen truppen
hätten die u boote und auch die schiffe
vor der küste mit raketen bestückt und
die raketen scharf gemacht man rechnet
also jetzt auch mit schwereren
raketenangriffen von see her und man hat
uns auch gewarnt dass strategische
bomber in der luft seien auch hier im
süden in der region wir waren heute an
der südfront mit bauern unterwegs oder
im hintergrund hörte man immer wieder
schwere artillerie donner das heißt die
gefechte gehen auch hier im süden massiv
weiter und in der nacht haben russische
truppen versucht durchzubrechen die
hatten sich verkleidet als ukrainische
truppen und habe versucht einen
checkpoint 1 dem konnten
zurückgeschlagen werden aber der
gouverneur und sein pressesprecher haben
uns gesagt man rechnet damit dass großen
versuchen auch hier im süden von
verschiedenen seiten die stadt nikolajew
einzunehmen das tor nach odessa noch
aber hätten sie nicht genügend truppen
dafür dankeschön
johannes hano nach odessa der krieg
fordert auch unter den soldaten beider
seiten viele opfer wohl deshalb hat das
russische parlament jetzt im
eilverfahren die geltende altersgrenze
für berufssoldaten aufgehoben bisher
durften russen die zum militär wollen
höchstens 40 jahre alt sein
in der ukraine ist der krieg auch fernab
der front allgegenwärtig wir haben
gehört sirenen warnen vor luftangriffen
soldaten müssen versorgt werden aber
auch immer neue flüchtlinge unser
reporter henner hebestreit hat sich in
mir pro umgesehen die viertgrößte stadt
des landes liegt rund 100 kilometer von
der front entfernt an der anlaufstelle
für geflüchtete der orthodoxen kirchen
ii pro lässt sich die lage im donbass
ablesen ständig mehr kommen zur größten
hilfs einrichtung ihrer art in der
ukraine
pro tag können sich hier 2500 menschen
versorgen die der krieg aus ihrer heimat
vertrieben hat ich bin jetzt hier nie
prowal ist viel ruhiger ist unsicherer
und unsere kinder keine angst mehr haben
müssen ich werde bestimmt nicht so bald
zurückkehren damit wächst der druck auf
die 900.000 einwohnerstadt offiziell
gemeldet sind die pro derzeit 90.000
geflohene bürgermeister vor lauter
vermutet dass es tatsächlich doppelt so
viele sind und noch viel mehr kommen
petrows gewusst die mopo sind anlass
werden die kämpfe im moment ständig
schlimmer deshalb gibt es dort immer
neue massenevakuierungen bis zu zwei
drittel der geflohen und kommen dann
erstmals sports hinten haben wir jetzt
schon die meisten flüchtenden
aufgenommen ist groß genug oder die
bauernhof ihre versorgung mit essen
medizin und hygieneartikeln wird immer
schwieriger noch dürfen sich die
geflüchteten hier alle drei wochen
wieder anstellen aber der gespendete
nachschub aus westeuropa bleibt
unterwegs immer öfter stecken
problematik unser problem ist der mangel
an waren nahrungsmittel weil uns in der
ukraine jetzt auch noch der treibstoff
ausgeht wird es immer schwieriger
hilfsgüter von der westgrenze aber nach
niveau zu bringen
20 tonnen nachschub brauchen sie schon
jetzt alle vier tage damit eltern und
ihre kinder mit dem nötigsten versorgt
werden können
drehen wir mal die uhr zurück london auf
dem höhepunkt der pandemie private
treffen sind verboten drum jeweils
johnson ruf zu vernunft und disziplin
auf keine partys nirgendwo es sei denn
man arbeitet in downing street number
ten da knallten die korken wie oft und
wie regelmäßig zeigt der
untersuchungsbericht der heute
veröffentlicht wurde peinlich aber kein
grund zum rücktritt mein thompson diana
zimmermann
wie es im locker und zugegangen ist an
seinem regierungssitz kann boris johnson
nun auf 37 seiten nachlesen der bericht
über party gate ist heraus spricht von
exzessivem alkoholkonsum bei mindestens
16 partys einer kultur des regel bruchs
führungsversagen und der groben
verletzung erwartbarer standards
der bericht hat unterstrichen dass die
politische führung in downing street die
verantwortung übernehmen muss und das
tue ich
ich stehe in demut vor ihnen und ich
habe etwas gelernt
gelernt hat johnston unter anderem dass
er am 13 november 2020 sehr wohl an
einer party in downing street
teilgenommen hatte auch wenn er das im
parlament verneint hat doch erst
vorgestern kamen bilder der sause ans
licht kein ungewöhnlicher anblick glaubt
man dieser anonymen zeugen
er hat nie gesagt könnt ihr bitte nach
hause gehen abstand einheiten eine maske
anziehen nein er hat sich meistens ein
glas für sich selbst genommen
empörung bei der opposition
der bericht zeigt die feuer liste sich
unter diesem premier im regierungssitz
ausgebreitet hat und er liefert den
ultimativen beweis mit wie viel
verachtung die menschen in diesem
gebäude auf die opfer blickten die die
briten erbracht haben und himmel doch
der premier wird nicht freiwillig
zurücktreten und die zeit läuft für ihn
morgen denen die abgeordneten in eine
parlamentspause nach den jubiläumsfeiern
für die queen so hofft boris johnson
wird die lust auf ein misstrauensvotum
gegen ihn erst einmal abgekühlt sein
die bundesregierung hat die entlastung
von millionen mietern beschlossen und
zwar bei der klimaabgabe die für den
ausstoß von co2 bezahlt werden muss
bislang zahlte dass der mieter allein
künftig wird der vermieter beteiligt er
muss zwischen null und 90 prozent
übernehmen je energieeffizienter das
haus desto weniger zahlt der vermieter
und band ihn hat heißt jeder der mit öl
oder gas heizt zahlt dafür auch die co2
steuer je nach wohnung oder haus sind
das schnell über 100 euro im jahr
obendrauf mieter will die ampel davon
jetzt teilweise entlasten
den co2 preis komplett tragen müssen
dass es aber nicht der sinn des co2
preise ist nie gewesen sondern erzielte
darauf den co2 ausstoß zu verringern
also im gebäudebereich die
sanierungsrate zu erhöhen geplant ist
dafür ein zehn stufen modell bei
emissionsarmen gebäuden zahlt weiter
allein der mieter die co2 steuer je
schlechter aber der energetische zustand
je höher also die emission desto mehr
muss sich der vermieter beteiligen mit
bis zu 90 prozent
das 10 in jedem fall beim mieter hängen
bleiben kritisieren verbraucherschützer
dieses zehn stufen modell ist zu gunsten
der vermieter ausgelegt und nicht
zugunsten der mieter das heißt die
mieter zahlen unter dem strich anteilig
mehr als die vermieter und das für ein
wenig in ordnung die vermieterseite
dagegen beklagt die neue regelung würde
keine anreize schaffen sondern
investitionen eher blockieren die
energetische modernisierung von den
gebäuden wird in den nächsten jahren und
jahrzehnten milliardenkosten es ist also
wichtig dass die eigentümer in der lage
sind zu investieren und das bedeutet
geld das einfach als steuer beim start
landet und nicht investiert werden kann
ist verlorenes geld die koalitionäre
selbst nennen es eine faire
lastenverteilung und versprechen einen
überschaubaren bürokratie aufwand gelten
soll das gesetz ab januar 2000 23
in schleswig holstein haben cdu und
grüne mit ihren koalitionsverhandlungen
begonnen am nachmittag ging es los zuvor
hatte nach den grünen auch die union den
gesprächen zugestimmt beide parteien
wollen innerhalb der nächsten drei
wochen einen koalitionsvertrag auf die
beine stellen eine reiche familien
sollen entlastet werden und zwar durch
eine neuregelung der beiträge zur
pflegeversicherung
das entschied das
bundesverfassungsgericht heute zwar
zahlen eltern einen niedrigeren
beitragssatz als kinderlose ab dem
zweiten kind seien sie aber durch den
zusätzlichen erziehungs aufwand im
nachteil die kläger hatten auch auf eine
senkung bei der renten und der
krankenversicherung gehofft hierfür sah
das gericht allerdings keine
notwendigkeit
wer braucht noch die kirche das ist ein
thema auf dem katholikentag der gerade
in stuttgart beginnt dort ringen die
gläubigen zum beispiel mit der haltung
ihrer kirche zu frauen im priesteramt zu
homosexualität oder geschlechter
identitäten zudem kämpfen sie gegen die
vertrauenskrise auch ausgelöst durch die
missbrauchsskandale in den vergangenen
jahren haben so viele katholiken ihre
kirche den rücken gekehrt eva schiller
er ist eine kleine sensation für die
katholische kirche ist transsexuell das
bistum hat ihm aber ausnahmsweise
erlaubt trotzdem religion zu
unterrichten nadia studiert theologie
und zweifel trotzdem auf dem weg zum
katholikentag es gibt zu wenig
priesteramtskandidaten es gibt zu wenig
pastoralreferentinnen also so wie die
katholische kirche momentan funktioniert
so wird sie nicht weiter funktionieren
können das ist halt so die große krugs
viele sagen das was sie da sonntags
predigen das halten die von montag bis
samstag nicht ein also wieso sollte ich
noch bei dem bleiben dieses schwanken
zwischen ärger und hoffnung ein viele
102 katholikentag
30.000 besucher werden erwartet nur halb
so viele wie beim letzten mal bei der
eröffnung fordert der bundespräsident
ein ende des ukraine kriegs und
erneuerung entscheidende ist glaube ich
vertuschung und schleppende aufklärung
viel vertrauen beschädigt bei manchen
zerstört haben und zugleich eben auch
viel selbstvertrauen ganz viel
selbstvertrauen der kirche und auch weil
die kirchenaustritte explodieren
versucht der katholikentag
auseinandersetzung mit dem thema
missbrauch mit sexueller vielfalt mit
besserer einbeziehung von frauen
die küche befindet sich in einer krise
das merken wir aber ich glaube umso
wichtiger ist es dass wir diese krise
besichtigen und es gibt nur
gemeinschaftlich diskursiv bei diesen
katholikentag das problem ist dass die
meisten konservativen kirchen stimme
nicht anreisen und so stellt sich die
frage wie viel es bringt wenn junge
katholiken reformen fordern echte
diskussion aber nicht möglich scheint
die holocaust-überlebende margot
friedländer ist für ihr engagement gegen
das vergessen der nazi gräueltaten
geehrt worden mit der ehrendoktorwürde
der freien universität berlin ihre
mission ihre geschichte zu erzählen sei
für sie eine herzensangelegenheit
sagt die 100 jährige es ist für uns
für die zukunft
es ist für die demokratie
sei
aber friedlich lohnt immer ihr zuzuhören
und jetzt hast du denn da ist andrea
petkovic war in der zweiten runde
ausgeschieden aber die deutsche nummer
eins angelique kerber die hat es in die
dritte runde geschafft ebenso
olympiasieger alexander zverev der
gewann in einem wahren fünfsatz tennis
krimi gegen den argentinier sebastian
beißer
zwei sätze lang scheint sich alles gegen
schwere verschworen zu haben auch der
wind sein 21 jahre alter gegner den er
vor kurzem noch in rom bezwungen hat
jagt ihn übers feld das wäre er der
favorit sebastian weiß er sich versieht
hat es wäre das 1 verloren 2 26 und dann
auch den zweiten mit 46 das nahe aus weg
zverevs kampfgeist die sätze 3 und 4
gingen klar an ihn nun gewinnt er die
ballwechsel die er zuvor verloren hat
nerven stark wert wäre vom fünften satz
zunächst einen matchball ab und
verwandelt selbst seinen ersten zum 7 5
nach mehr als dreieinhalb stunden ein
großer kampf gegen einen starken gegner
und gegen die eigenen nerven
die roten teufel haben es geschafft und
sind zurück in liga zwei gestern abend
der 2 0 sieg im relegations rückspiel
gegen dresden heute abend die große
party auf dem stiftsplatz in
kaiserslautern mit tausenden fck fans
die nach vier jahren drittklassigkeit
die rückkehr in die zweite
fußball-bundesliga feiern
die sachsen dagegen zum vierten mal in
der vereinsgeschichte abgestiegen in
liga drei
der fc kaiserslautern hat diesmal die
wichtigen tore gemacht und steht vor
einem neuanfang endlich wieder zweitliga
sensationell gut so nämlich aufräumt
voller stolz auf die mannschaft auf das
was er in diesem jahr geleistet hat es
war die 59 10 minute in der der aufstieg
mit dem 1 0 durch daniel hanzlik form
annahmen dresden nicht chancenlos in
diesem spiel doch philipp hercher machte
mit dem 2 0 in der nachspielzeit den
zweitliga traum für lautern perfekt das
spiel endete zwar mit pyro wahnsinn der
dresdner fans feuer böller
spielunterbrechung danach konnte
kaiserslautern aber jubeln als stolz
sagt 2 klick ist
die botschaft lautet ja stimmt wir haben
uns das lotto für sie die gewinnzahlen
lauten 15 15 28 32 45 und die superzahl
5 weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
der feiertag morgen bringt den meisten
kühles und trockenes wetter wo schauer
zu erwarten sind sagt uns gleich katja
horneffer marietta slomka freut sich auf
sie im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
und wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen
wieder dabei sind danke für ihr
interesse einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]
guten abend noch ist der mai nicht um
und er war in vielen regionen
deutschlands bislang viel zu trocken da
haben sich sicher einige über den regen
in baden württemberg in bayern und auch
hier in sachsen gefreut am nachmittag
zogen dann regenschauer über
norddeutschland hinweg es war noch
einzelne gewitter dabei jetzt geht es
wechselhaft weiter und es wird kühler
heute nacht sinken die temperaturen auf
werte zwischen 13 und 7 grad und an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee fällt etwas
regen richtung süden ist es zum teil
auch klar über norddeutschland ziehen
dann morgen einige regenschauer hinweg
zwischendurch werden sie aber auch
häufiger die sonne sehen können bei
westwind mit jedem kilometer weiter
richtung süddeutschland wird es sonniger
und am meisten sonne gibt es morgen
zwischen dem berchtesgadener land und
dem allgäu es gibt nicht nur in sachen
sonnenschein ein süd-nord-gefälle
sondern auch was die temperaturen
betrifft denn am wärmsten wird es morgen
am oberrhein mit 23 grad an den küsten
von nord- und ostsee bleibt es bei 16
oder 17 grad kälter und diese kalte luft
flutet in den nächsten tagen ganz
deutschland am sonntag sind es nur noch
12 bis 19 grad und besonders im
nordosten gibt es in den nächsten tagen
noch schauer und gewitter gute nacht